[APPLAUSE]
NIKIL SAVAL: Thank
you all for coming.
Thank you for inviting
me to your office
to talk about the
history the office.
It's very, very cool that
you would take time out
of your lunch hour to see me.
I feel like lunch is sacred, so
this is very, very gratifying
for me.
So thank you, thank
you for coming.
So, my book is a
history of the office.
The workplace-- not the show.
You don't know many times
I've had to say that.
It's actually people--
when I'm like, yeah,
I'm writing this book, it's
a history of the office.
And they're like, that
sounds super boring.
And they're just like,
why did you-- you mean,
you just watch the show
and you wrote about it?
And then I have to
explain, and then they're
like, that sounds
even more boring.
Why would you do
that with your day?
You don't even work-- I
don't work in an office now,
because I write books.
But, why I would do that
seemed to many people
very masochistic.
Maybe it is.
But I just want
to talk today-- I
will start by talking about the
history of the office, where
I locate the origin of
the office in the book,
and then I'll talk about
the most important part
of the history of
the office, which
is when I enter the office.
That was a big day for
work, when they let me in.
And people often ask me why I
got interested in the topic,
and of course I got interested
because I had an office job.
And I took my interest
just a little too far
and got obsessed.
And then I want to conclude
with the thing that
became the seed for the
book in general, which
is the curious history of
the office cubicle, which,
like everything, I think
is super fascinating.
It's chiefly because
it-- and some of you
may know this a little bit--
that the original office
cubicle was meant to
liberate office workers,
and it turned into this symbol
of white collar servitude.
And how that happened
I think is paradigmatic
for the general story
of the way we work
and what's going on now.
And then I think we
could talk-- there's
some stuff towards
the end of the book,
and then stuff I've written
about the so-called future
of the office, which we could
talk about or in a Q&A setting.
So, some of this is some
material from the book.
Some of it is fresh.
So, thank you for having me.
This is from the origin of the
office about clerical workers.
They labored in poorly lit,
smoky single rooms, attached
to merchants and lawyers, to
insurance concerns and banks.
They had sharp penmanship and
bad eyes, extravagant clothes
but shrunken,
unused bodies, backs
cramped from poor
posture, fingers
calloused by constant writing.
When they were not thin,
angular, and sallow,
they were ruddy and soft.
Their paunches sagged
on to their thighs.
Clerks were once a rare
subject in literature.
Their lives were considered
unworthy of comment,
their workplaces
hemmed in and small,
their work indescribably dull.
And yet, one of the
greatest of short stories
is about a clerk, "Bartleby, the
Scrivener" by Herman Melville.
Melville would become famous
for writing memoirs and novels
about spectacular sea
voyages to exotic islands.
He became famous but he lost
the readership eventually
with this strange, long
book about a whaling voyage.
He decided to turn inward
after this, weirdly.
I mean, if you write all these
books about whaling and stuff,
it's odd that your
next choice would
be to write about the
snug, suffocating world
of the office, and to
exchange the titanic hunt
for the white whale to the
hunt for the right size pen.
And he writes a lot about
finding the right position
to sit at a desk.
This is from "Bartleby,
the Scrivener."
"If, for the sake
of easing his back,
he brought the table
lid at a sharp angle,
well up towards
this chin, and wrote
there like a man using the
steeple roof of a Dutch house
for his desk, then he declared
that it stopped the circulation
in his arms.
If now he lowered the
table to his waistband
and stooped over it
in writing, then there
was a sore aching in his back."
So, you see this is the story
of the standing desk from 1853.
Melville was really progressive
in his office design.
Melville had worked
for a few years
as a scrivener on Wall Street,
the setting of Bartleby,
some years before
he took to the ship.
He knew from inside, therefore,
the peculiar emptiness
that office work could have.
Its atmosphere of
what he thought
was purposeless labor
and dead-endedness.
Even in "Moby Dick" he speaks
of the thousands in Manhattan
who idle along the battery, lost
in what he calls "sea reverie."
And they just are
lost because they
want to avoid returning
to their work lives,
"pent up in lathe and
plaster, tied to counters,
nailed to benches,
clinched to desks."
In "Bartleby, the Scrivener,"
the few windows in the office
look out onto nothing
but more walls.
"On one end," the
unnamed narrator writes,
"the window faced the
white wall of the interior
of a spacious skylight shaft,
penetrating the building
from top to bottom,
and on the other side,
there was an unobstructed
view of a brick wall,
black by age and
everlasting shade."
"This wall," the
narrator adds wryly,
"required no spyglass to bring
out its lurking beauties,
but, for the benefit of
all nearsighted spectators,
was pushed within 10
feet of my window panes.
On two sides, then, two
walls-- the white wall
of the light shaft, on the
other, a soot-black brick
wall hemming in
vision and light.
It was a room with no view."
What Bartleby means has been
a subject of endless debate.
There was even a film a few
years ago called "Bartleby"
set in a cubicle office, but
it was just the same story.
Office workers have
always taken it
to be a mirror of-- of a
bad office, bad office work.
And Bartleby's famous phrase,
"I would prefer not to"--
when his boss asks
him to work, he just
says "I would prefer
not to"-- it's
the encapsulation of
how the office has
its way of reducing all titanic
conflicts to petty grievances
and simmering resentments.
The funny thing is that
in 1853-- this story
is so prophetic-- but
when it was written,
the term "office" itself,
and the sort of labor
that was performed
there, had nowhere
near the universal
significance it has now.
In those tense years
before the Civil War,
clerks were just a small
and unusual phenomenon,
a subject of anxious scrutiny.
There were places that
where at once centers
of American business
and breeding
grounds for a kind of work
that nobody recognized as work.
Clerks were a kind of worker
that seemed, like Bartleby,
at once harmless and ominous.
Bartleby, then,
was early evidence
that the office had just
begun to blot its inky mark
on the consciousness
of the world.
People ask me often,
because I've-- it's tragic,
I've become an office
expert-- they ask me,
where does the office begin?
What's the first office?
And this is actually a question
without an easy answer.
You can just start with
the origins of paperwork
itself, which is,
until quite recently,
the most common association
with office work was paper.
I still use it.
You can think of the
derogatory phrase
"paper pusher," which is
increasingly becoming obsolete.
I don't know what-- we should
come up with a new phrase.
You push code, is that right?
But what else-- we
can work on this.
In other words, since
the invention of writing,
and the corresponding
ability to keep records
in a systematic manner,
there have always
been places that resemble
offices-- monasteries,
libraries, scholar's studies.
Banking has always furnished
an especially large amount
of paperwork.
The Uffizi gallery
in Florence was also
one of the first office
buildings, the bookkeeping
offices of the Medici family.
Clerks have existed for ages.
Many of them became
quite famous.
There's the diarist Samuel
Pepys, the British government
diarist who is a major source
of knowledge about 17th century
England.
Alexander Hamilton was
the merchant's clerk
before he became
Secretary of the Treasury.
Benjamin Franklin, paragon
of pecuniary restraint
and bourgeois self-abnegation,
was a dry goods clerk.
Some of the tediousness
in his own writing
may have been honed in the
conditions of his first job.
Since clerks have had the
opportunity to keep diaries,
they've bemoaned
the sheer boredom
of their tasks--
the endless copying,
the awkward postures, the
meaningless of their work.
When not doing
writing for their job,
clerks have cultivated their
habit of writing about the job,
or literally around.
There's some infamous
marginalia we
have from medieval scribes--
on the sides of manuscripts
they were copying,
they were so bored
that they would just
continue to write
about how bored they were.
"Writing is excessive drudgery,"
once such jotting reads,
"it crooks your back,
it dims your sight,
it twists your stomach
and your sides."
And then one scribbling
on one manuscript just
goes, "Oh my hand."
And that was just dumb,
because actually writing out
that sentence is worse-- then
your hand gets-- Anyways,
clerks were not super smart.
So, you could say that this
is all the office work, right?
But I take a different tack.
I think if you were to find
the emergence of the office
in history, the workplace
that really prefigures
the offices of today,
even if it doesn't
look like, say, the office
we're in right now--
not superficially,
anyway-- you have
to look at a peculiar confluence
of new sorts of buildings,
deep economic
changes, as well as--
and this is the
most slippery of all
to pin down-- new kinds of
feelings and mass awareness
of one another in the workforce.
And this, I think,
starts to happen--
I locate this in the mid- 19th
century in America and England,
but you see this
elsewhere as well.
At that time, industrialization
in Britain and America
was producing more and
more administrative work,
and alongside it, the need
for a rational approach
to managing accounts,
bills, and ledgers.
In short, paperwork.
And rising to take these
positions were clerks.
And this is the key thing.
They're looking around.
They began to feel
that they themselves
were part of some
new special group.
There was this sort
of sense of we clerks.
They didn't all
say office workers,
but they knew that they
belonged to something different
and their kind of
work was different.
So one finds the office
coinciding, then,
with the change in the position
of the clerks themselves.
It's a new restiveness on their
part, a new sense of power.
They're not sure of themselves,
but they're no longer isolated.
By the middle of
the 19th century,
clerks in their
workplaces begin to appear
with the new regularity in
literature and journalism.
And so Bartleby, with its
simultaneously assertive
and retiring
protagonist, I think
nicely captures this
ambivalence of the early world
of the office.
What Bartleby also
captures, what
makes it so great as a short
story, is that, at the time,
people really thought
office work was unnatural.
At the time in the US,
shipping and farming, building
and assembling-- these were
the natural order of work.
And in this, clerks
just didn't seem to fit.
It's odd, because
at the time, they
were the fastest growing
sector of the workforce
in the late 19th century.
In 1880, less than 5% of
the workforce, about 186,000
people, was in the
clerical profession.
But in cities, they were
the fastest growing.
In some mercantile
cities like New York,
they had become ubiquitous.
The 1855 census recorded clerks
as the city's third largest
occupational group, just
behind servants and laborers.
So you had manual workers
and then office workers,
and this was, for many,
a terrible development.
Nothing about clerical labor
was congenial to the way
most Americans thought of work.
Clerks didn't work the
land, lay railroad tracks,
make ammunitions in factories,
let alone hide away in a cabin
by a small pond to raise
beans and live deep.
Unlike farming or
factory work, office work
didn't produce anything.
At best, it seemed
to reproduce things.
Clerks copied endlessly,
bookkeepers added up numbers
to create more numbers,
and insurance men literally
made more paper.
For the tobacco farmer or
miner, it was not work.
He-- the clerk-- was
a kind of parasite
to them on the work of
others, and they really
did the heavy lifting.
And so the stereotype
of workers was
that they were sinewy,
tanned by the relentless sun
or blackened by smokestack soot.
And the bodies of clerks
were slim, almost feminine,
in their untested delicacy.
The press took a lot of time,
a shocking amount of time,
leveling invectives
against clerks.
This is from a big journal of
the time, The American Whig
Review, "We venture
the assertion
that there is not a more
dependent or subservient set
of men in this country than
of the genteel dry goods
clerks in this and
other large cities."
The American
Phrenological Journal
had stronger advice
for young men facing
the prospect of a
clerical career.
They said, "Don't do it,
be men instead, therefore.
And with true courage
and manliness,
dash into the
wilderness with your axe
and make an opening
for the sunlight
and for an independent home.
Vanity Fair had the
strongest language of all.
They said clerks were "vain,
mean, selfish, greedy, sensual,
and sly, talkative,
and cowardly."
And they spent all their
minimal strength attempting
to dress better than "real
men who did real work."
It was somehow never questioned
that journalism, which was also
conducted in offices
with pen and paper,
constituted real work.
That would have been
too complicated.
The attire of clerks was
a barb for the press.
The very concept
of business attire
came into being
around this time.
There's a manual of
etiquette from this time that
writes, "In the counting
room in the office,
gentleman wear frock
coats or sack coats.
They need not be of
very fine material,
and should not be of
any garish pattern."
There are other fashion
advisers of the time that
pointed to a host of
business coats, business
surtouts, business paletots,
you could find at new stores.
There was a store at the time
called Brooks Brother's, which
came up to clothe
office workers.
You may know it.
Working class Americans
were seen in straight straw
hats or green
blouses, but the clerk
had a certain kind of collar.
It was usually bleached
in immaculate white,
and it was starched
into imposing stiffness.
The color business shirts
were actually quite expensive,
so even Brooks Brother's used
to sell collars by themselves.
You would buy your white
collar and put it on.
And half a dozen collars is
about the cost of a shirt.
And so this is kind
of a key thing.
The white collar was
detachable, and yet it
was essential as
a status marker.
It was sort of
the perfect symbol
of what was pseudo- genteel,
the dual nature of office work.
And this clerk became a
subject of satire in fiction.
Edgar Allen Poe wrote a story
called "The Man of the Crowd,"
where he's observing
this tribe of clerks,
and it's composed entirely
of overdressed dandies,
imitating aristocratic
styles several years old.
This is from that story.
"There were the junior clerks of
flash houses-- young gentleman
with tight coats, bright
boots, well-oiled hair,
and supercilious lips.
Setting aside a
certain dapperness
of carriage, which
may be termed deskism
for want of a better word,
the manner of these persons
seemed to me an exact
facsimile of what
had been the perfect bon ton of
about 12 or 18 months before."
"They wore the castoff
graces of the gentry,
and this, I believe,
involves the best definition
of the class.
The division of the upper
clerks of staunch firms,
or of the "steady old fellows,"
it was not possible to mistake.
These were known by their
coats and pantaloons
of black or brown,
made to sit comfortably
with cravats and
waistcoats, broad solid
looking shoes and thick
hose and gaiters."
"They all had
slightly bald heads,
from which the right ears,
long used to pen-holding,
had an odd habit of
standing off on end.
I observed that they always
removed or settled their hats
with both hands,
and wore watches
with short gold chains of
a substantial and ancient
pattern.
Theirs was the affectation
of respectability,
if indeed there be an
affectation so honorable."
This is quite nice, a quite
loving portrait of clerks.
Satirical but loving.
Walt Whitman, the poet,
had different words.
He set out to
establish that clerking
was antithetical to
American democracy.
He wrote this piece
called "Broadway,"
where he's observing
clerks coming down
Broadway in New York City.
And this is around the 1850s.
And he writes, "A slender and
round-shouldered generation,
of minute leg, chalky
face, and hollow chest.
They were trig and
prim in great glow
of shiny boots, clean
shirts, sometimes
now of an extraordinary
pattern, as if
overrun with bugs, tight
pantaloons, straps-- which
seem to be coming
into fashion again--
startling cravats, and
hair all soaked and slick
with sickening oils.
"What wretched, spindling,
forked radishes would they be,
and how ridiculously would
their natty demeanor appear,
if suddenly they could
all be stripped naked."
So, he didn't like clerks.
And the funny thing is the
sense of clerks as being weak,
unmanly, they looked thin and
they didn't do heavy lifting
unless they lifted
boxes, this was
perceived by clerks themselves.
And this is sort of led to
the culture of the modern gym.
At the time, you
find a lot of clerks
writing about going the gym.
They're like, "we have
to not be narrow chested,
like Whitman says we are.
I advise everyone
to go to the gym."
So, in a way that
hasn't changed.
This fantasy that Whitman had
of stripping clerks naked,
exposing the clerk to
his own inadequacy,
I think only concealed
a deeper fear
about the changing world
of American business.
Under the pressures of
growing industrialization
in the north of
the United States,
the Jeffersonian
democracy of farmers
was heading towards the
same fate as the buffalo.
More importantly, the
old 18th century world
of businessmen who were
also craftsman, white collar
types who worked
with their hands
began to suffer a slow
decline as merchants
and their groups
of clerks started
to exploit their superior
knowledge of distant markets,
and industries begin to require
more and more bookkeepers
to maintain their ever
more complicated accounts.
The growth of manufacturing
led to myriad urban retail
and wholesale
establishments, which,
in turn, required more clerks.
The basis of prosperity,
Hunt's Merchants' Magazine
held in 1839, lay in
"the vast modern increase
of the facilities for
defusing and obtaining
full and correct
information on everything
pertaining to trade."
The people who handled
this were clerks.
Cities began to acquire ever
more sizable numbers of clerks,
ambling down the broad
avenues for men like Whitman
to gawk and fret over.
By 1860, 25% of
Philadelphians were
working in non-manual
occupations.
In the brand-new city of San
Francisco, it was already 36%.
In Boston, it was 40.
Not all of them were clerks,
but the trend was clear.
More and more people had
ceased to work with their hands
and were now working
with their heads.
The journals of
opinion in the US
might have hated the wretched,
spindling office worker,
but the hatred refracted
the intense ambivalence
over the nature of business,
and that clerks might not
be an aberration but the future.
So that's a little bit
about the origin the office.
Now, like I said, I want to
talk about the origin of me
in the office, which
is a great story.
Ever since I began
writing this book,
people have asked me
where the idea came from.
Why, given the many paths
available to a person
in the world, especially with
a certain level of education
and skills, would I
choose to spend years
in my life studying desks,
and chairs, and file cabinets,
typing pools,
accounting machines,
demountable partitions, steel-
reinforced masonry, curtain
walls, and, of course, cubicles?
Why, moreover, would
I want to be reading
esoteric treatises like the
marketing plans for Herman
Miller Furniture in 1962,
studies from journals
of organizational
psychology from 1920,
the proceedings of the
International Association
of Office Managers from 1935?
Why on earth would I want to
spend serious time plumbing
the hallucinatory treatises of
erstwhile superstar business
guru Tom Peters for
insight into the mind
and life of the American
white collar worker?
Months after
finishing the book--
I really don't have an
answer that satisfies me--
but here, at the very least, is
a provisional attempt at one.
The idea for a
book on the office
first came to me when I
was working in an office.
I got my first job
straight out of college.
This was lucky, even in the
comparatively flush years
of 2005, which the
economically- minded among you
will remember as one of the
peaks of the "jobless recovery"
in the United States that
followed the dot- com
crash of 2000, 2001, 2002.
I was working in a large
corporate publishing
house, one of the biggest
in the world, with branches
all over the place.
It's named after a
certain tuxedo- colored
species of Arctic animal.
I don't want to
name first names,
so I'll just call
it Polar Bear Books.
At Polar Bear Books, I
was an editorial assistant
in the business books imprint,
helping to acquire and edit
scintillating treatises
on brand management
and endless attempts to one-up
to Clayton Christensen's book,
"The Innovator's Dilemma."
Please do not write
any more books
about "The Innovator's Dilemma."
There are so many.
"The Innovator's
Problem," "The Innovator's
Solution," just ugh.
Anyway.
So many.
The work was nine to
five, pretty much,
and the hierarchies were
very straightforward,
the atmosphere
pleasantly corporate,
the office design as
traditional as could
be, the corridor
offices around the side,
cubicles in the middle.
My cubicle was enormous.
It had tons of shelf space.
I spent a shocking amount of
company time pinning things
to it.
Cartoons, poetry,
color printouts
from the office
printer-- which are
very expensive for the office.
And then I was doing this when
I wasn't wandering the office
and gossiping to
anyone I could find.
Over time, I started to tire
of ordering my boss's lunch--
although it was the one
thing I did really well--
and some of the more mindless
work I was tasked with.
More damaging to my
morale was the fact
that every so often,
a friend I had made
would disappear,
or be disappeared.
It wasn't that they had
left for another company,
it was that they had
been fired or laid off.
No one would be told
of their leaving.
Suddenly, their items
and their presence
would be spirited
away, and one would
have to go to great lengths to
find out why, say, a long- time
editor with a newborn
child had been thrown out
into one of the grimmer job
markets in recent memory
without so much as a
word of explanation.
To many of you, this might
seem naive on my part,
but to me, an ingenue
in the brutal world
of American capitalism,
it was something
I found difficult to stomach.
So I left for another
publishing house.
It was a smaller place
with a more academic list,
sort of a crossover list.
It was more interesting, I
had more control over my work,
but the pay-- the
work was harder.
My pay was $30,000 a year.
You should all
gasp at this fact.
In New York City,
it's not a lot.
Or anywhere.
It's just horrible.
It remained the same,
but my hours got worse.
The books- to- staff
ratio was twice
that of the previous company.
My benefits were also worse.
My health care costs increased.
My boss made me work nights
and come in on weekends,
chiefly because I
worked in publishing,
and one only does that, she
said, because you love it.
One way of learning
not to love it
is to work day after day, hour
after hour without overtime.
At the same time, the
office arrangement
became more precarious.
The lighting in the central
area was alternately
poor or overbearing, where
my area was dark and obscure,
one of my friends--
a rather pale,
blond specimen of humanity-- was
under a poorly placed skylight,
which meant that if he
sat in place all day,
as indeed he had
to, he would burn.
He placed a piece
of poster board
on top of the cubicle walls
as a kind of retractable roof,
like where do the
Dallas Cowboys play?
It was a kind of dome to keep
himself from being scorched.
My own cubicle was
smaller than before,
and my back to my boss's
door, which had me constantly
looking over my shoulder to
make sure no one was watching.
And then when she
closed the door,
I was even more freaked out.
I mean, closed doors.
There's nothing scarier than
sitting out in a cubicle
and watching two people behind
you just walk into an office
and close the door.
Because you're
like, what are they
talking about that I can't hear?
So, I said the
workload was punishing,
the job situation precarious.
Halfway through my time
there, an entire department
was laid off, just months
after a few had been hired,
with the CEO saying that he was
caving to a painful reality.
I knew that something
had to be done,
but I had no way of
understanding what that meant.
I lazily tried to
talk my coworkers
into considering unionizing.
But the thing about white-
color offices in America
is that the idea
of a union hardly
ever enters an
office worker's mind.
The office both looks
like and is structurally
set up to be a meritocracy.
You can rise from the
cubicle to the corner office.
At the same time, everyone knows
that this isn't always true.
There's personalities,
there's petty politics,
all sorts of unfair
situations can
intervene to make
the idea of merit
a farce in some situations.
At the same time, the
idea of organizing
to make the division
between management and labor
less arbitrary
counters everything
I think that we believe
about office life.
The fact that any clerical
worker or junior staff member,
when you start at
the bottom, you're
a junior businessman
in training.
Business person.
This central contradiction
of office life I think
makes it at once a source for
many people and inevitably,
for just as many people,
a source of frustration--
a source of hope as well
as a source of frustration.
So, eventually I
quit this place.
I was sick of overwork,
and I discover
that I could make the
same amount of money,
weirdly, as a temp in
a job that sucked less
of my mental energy, my
spirit, and my the time.
I got a job-- I
was placed, really,
working for a private
equity firm on Park Avenue.
This was before the
financial crisis.
So, flush years--
not for temps, but I
wasn't taking in commission.
But I was working in
a cubicle suite shared
by two other administrative
assistants who gabbed all day.
And I felt like I had been
squeezed in my cubicle.
I believe that it
was two by two feet.
I know that's
physically impossible,
but it certainly felt that way.
I was like this the whole time.
But it was meant to encourage
greater interaction, they said.
My bosses liked me,
but eventually they
realized I wasn't
doing much work there,
so they moved me to a
larger cubicle right next
to a very powerful
air conditioner.
In the midst of summer,
I wrapped myself
in wool sweaters
and scarves while I
muddled through
PowerPoints about how
to get more state pension funds
to invest in private equity.
Eventually I was
out of there too.
And by that point,
I was researching
the history the office
as a freelancer.
And then I started to
realize the irony in this.
I realized I had gone through
all the stages of being
an office worker since the
middle of the 20th century
in about two years.
I had started in a very
cushy, corporate firm
in sort of like a 1950s place.
I had moved to a more precarious
and entrepreneurial spot, where
everything was on the verge of
collapse or being bought out,
sort of like the 1980s.
And, after a stint
as a temporary worker
in a rich firm of
high equity investors
performing skillful
leveraged buyouts
of various public
companies, I was on my own.
My capacious cubicle that I
had suddenly been squeezed out
of that I had been in, had
something been squeezed out
of existence.
And it was at this
point that I started
researching the history
of the office cubicle.
The curious thing about
the office cubicle
is that-- and I'll
sort of talk about this
and then we can break to
Q&A-- the reason I got
so interested in the
history of the office
is that I just
started researching,
why do we work in cubicles?
Maybe you guys don't?
I haven't actually
seen the office here.
Do you guys have cubes?
I know Mountainview
some people do, right?
I've seen that.
And the cubicle is
a symbol, right?
No word is more
efficient than cubicle.
You just say cubicle and
then just waves of horror
can wash over people.
Cubicle farms, cubicle
infernos, cubicle warrens.
There's terms like six
packs for packs of cubicles.
And maybe you guys
know this stuff?
And then you're prairie
dogging, looking
over the top of the cubicle.
Dilbert, Office Space.
The line in Office
Space-- "Human beings
were not meant to sit
in cubicles staring
at computer screens all day."
It's one of the purest words
in the English language
for connecting dread and
insecurity and anxiety.
But, when I looked
into the history,
I discovered that it was not
at all meant to be the case.
And the way that
what was designed
as the origin of the cubicle had
become its antithesis, I think,
is one of the paradigmatic
stories of the office.
I'd like to tell it to you now.
It's so exciting.
Let me just check the time.
In 1964, the iconic
furniture design company
Herman Miller unveiled an office
plan unlike anything anyone
had ever seen.
Called Action Office,
it was the brainchild
of Robert Probst, who was
among the first designers
to argue that office
work was mental work.
He actually used the
term knowledge work.
This is one of the
earliest uses of this term.
It had been coined by
Peter Drucker in 1962.
Anyway, so Probst was
one of the first to argue
that office work was mental
work and that mental effort
was tied to
environmental enhancement
of one's physical capabilities.
Rather than a furniture item
or a collection of them,
Action Office was a proposition
for an altogether new kind
of space.
Most office designs
at the timer were
about keeping people in place.
I think people are
familiar with the images,
if you've watch "Mad
Men," of course,
but if you've also seen "The
Apartment," the great film
from the '60s, or "The
Crowd," an the earlier film,
or "How to Succeed in Business
Without Really Trying," where
you have rows of
desks in a steno pool,
or an accounting pool,
and then corridor
offices around the side.
And people don't know
this, but this was really
modeled on factories.
This came out of, in
the early 20th century,
people were like,
what are offices?
I'm being silly, but
really they didn't
know what to do with these
administrative spaces,
and the only model workplace
that they had was the factory.
So they assumed that the
office was a kind of paperwork
factory, it should be
organized accordingly.
People should clock in and out.
You file into this
place, and effectively
are a paperwork assembly
line, and only when
you each achieve a
certain level of prestige
do you get an
office of your own.
So this was about status,
it was about place,
it was about prestige.
Probst hated this.
He thought offices
should be about movement.
should be about being
conducive to whatever kind of
work you had to do at the time.
Advertisements for
Action Office at the time
show workers in constant motion.
Indeed, the human
figures in the images
often appear blurred,
as if the photographer
were unable to capture
their lightning speed.
You have to imagine what
it was like in the 1960s.
Probst, he thought
of office workers
as kind of futurist
soccer players.
They were just
constantly in motion,
they were doing knowledge
work here and then standing up
and doing knowledge work
there and then sitting down.
And it was this
incredibly dynamic idea
of what office life was.
It was the result of an
unusual collaboration.
Probst had been through
together with one
of his near opposites,
George Nelson.
Some of you who are
interested in design,
you would know the name.
He's one of the great
mid-century furniture
designers, just
designers in general.
He grew to prominence
by converting
the ideas of modernism into
effortlessly cool pieces
of furniture.
Probst was laconic,
prophetic, intransigent,
he exuded the tight- lipped
silence of the American West.
He was from Colorado.
Nelson, by contrast,
was a scotch-
swilling bon vivant
and raconteur.
I don't know, have people seen
the show "True Detective?"
Someone told me that oh
yeah, Nelson and Probst
is kind of like Woody Harrelson
and Matthew McConaughey.
Does that sound right?
No.
It's such a bizarre
comparison that someone even
thought of that anyway.
The items Nelson had
designed for Action Office
were beautiful, at once
homey and utterly modern,
nostalgic and forward thinking.
His desk surfaces rested on
cantilevered die- cast aluminum
legs.
There was a standing desk,
where a chrome brace doubled
as a foot rest, and it was
a roll- top standing desk.
These are very
beautiful objects,
if you ever have the
chance to look them up.
A communication center
with the telephone
was acoustically
insulated for phone calls.
There were many
idiosyncratic touches,
because Probst had convinced
himself that work out of sight
was work out of mind.
There were no
large desk drawers.
Instead, there was a
movable display surface
from which items could be
retrieved and replaced at ease.
The standing desk kept workers
off their feet-- on their feet,
rather-- but also allowed them
to leave work out overnight,
securely closed.
It was also very colorful.
It was green, bright blue,
navy blue, black, and yellow,
unlike the office
furniture you find here.
But this was very strange
in the '60s, and, in a way,
it remains strange.
It was like a magazine
advertisement, the pop art
at the time of
Warhol Lichtenstein.
Action Office at the
time was very '60s.
It proclaimed its allegiance
to the spirit of the age.
It was rich,
advanced, liberating.
In this sense, the Action
Office that Probst had conceived
and Nelson designed might have
been the first truly modern
idea turned to the office.
The first in which
the aesthetics
of design and progressive
ideas about human needs
were truly united.
When Action Office was
unveiled before the press,
the answer was
resoundingly affirmative.
"Seeing these designs,"
wrote the writers
of Industrial Design, "one
wonders why office workers have
put up with their incompatible,
unproductive, uncomfortable
environment for so long."
Meanwhile, the more popular
Saturday Evening Post
cried, "Office workers
of America, beware!
The Action Office is coming.
We are in real danger
of being enabled
to work at 100% efficiency."
Despite the rapturous reviews,
Action Office didn't sell.
Office managers complained
that the entire system
was too expensive
because the furniture was
made of such quality material.
And the space that
Action Office created
was too vaguely defined,
its borders too porous.
The product won a few
awards in the industry,
within the furniture
industry, but it otherwise
saw little adoption
in the workplace.
Probst had sort run up against
a classic problem of design.
Office planners
and architects tend
to imagine that the set
up of their own offices
should be the way that
everyone should work.
They pretend that their
subjective methods are
objective, empirical
results, and then they
try to impose them
on a workplace.
In a way, you see this all
over the place with open office
plans, where people just don't
always work in a certain way
that they're just imposed.
Unfortunately, the
copycat Action Offices
were starting to have
strange, unforeseen effects
in other workplaces.
Rather than making
them more flexible,
they, in fact, appeared to be
making them more regimented.
Douglas Ball, a designer for
the rival furniture company
Hayworth, came up with one
of the many knock-off designs
for the Canadian company Sunar.
Initially excited, he emerged
from the completed space
utterly depressed.
"I went to see the first
installation of the Sunar
system, the huge government
project," he said.
"The panels were
all 70 inches tall.
So, unless you were
six foot three,
you couldn't look over the top.
It was awful, one of the worst
installations I'd ever seen.
We thought it was extremely
flexible in the plan view,
but we'd never considered
the vertical elevation.
And it was too late
to fix the problem."
He had trapped people in
giant fabric- wrapped walls,
when he had meant, like
Probst, to free them.
It turned out that companies
had no interest in creating
autonomous environments
for their human performers.
Instead, they wanted to stuff
as many people in a small space
for as cheaply as possible,
as quickly as possible.
By 1978, Probst
was composing memos
on repositioning his
design, panicked over
the obsession with "easily
defined and accountable cost
savings."
He wrote, "Meanwhile,
other matters
of more profound influence
on the real productivity
of organizations have
slipped into the background,"
he worried.
Action Office had been
meant for flexibility.
Instead, a new
rigidity set in that
was wrapped disingenuously
in humanistic fabric.
Probst memos seemed
to have no effect.
Soon, the designs for Action
Office in the Herman Miller
brochures began to
seem more box-like.
They were selling what
the companies wanted.
In 1998, a journalist
interviewed Robert Probst,
then 77 years old, for
Metropolis Magazine.
He defended the
features that had
made his designed so
popular-- its austerity,
its flexibility--
but he conceded
what he hadn't been
willing to understand then.
"The dark side of this is
that not all organizations are
intelligent and
progressive," Probst said.
"Lots are run by
crass people, who
can take the same
kind of equipment
and create hell holes."
Probst noted that his design had
proved irrepressibly popular.
40 million employees
in America at the time
worked in 42 different
versions of the Action Office.
But he failed to note
that, by that point,
they were all known by the
same name-- the cubicle.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Take questions?
Just like what the
I think yeah, you
might need to step to the mic.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: So, it
seems like there's
a balance between what's
good for the employee
and what's good for the company,
in terms of productivity,
however you want to describe it.
So, you talked a
little bit earlier
about the future of
where this is all going.
So, I'd be curious-- given
the fact that companies
are specifically here to make
as much money as possible,
or improve products, make
the world a better place--
what would you say
the future looks like?
How do you define the
balance between what's
good for the employee and
what's good for the company?
NIKIL SAVAL: It's a
very hard question.
Predictions are
always sort of wrong.
Predictions are often
wrong, as everyone knows.
Now that I've seen
lots of attempts
to define the future the
office in the last 150 years,
it's shocking how
often people are right
but also how much they're wrong.
The question though,
about worker satisfaction,
about worker's
control over what it
is they do, vis-a-vis the
organization they work for
and what organizations
think is valuable,
is definitely changing a lot.
I think one thing
that we should--
just to take one
part of that, one way
to look at the
future of the office
is to look at the increasing
informalization-- I guess
you call it-- casualization
of the workforce.
There are many, many more
people at the present working
in contract positions,
as independent workers,
as freelancers, as temps,
than there have been probably
since the 19th century.
Those terms didn't exist,
but it's something similar.
It's hard to estimate, but it's
somewhere between 25 and 30%.
Some people think this is
the fastest- growing sector
of the workforce.
And a lot of this is
not conscious decision
making on those workers' part.
A lot of people are thrown
out into independent work.
People I know cannot get
permanent employment.
But a lot of it, in a way, is
a certain kind of disaffection,
I think, with companies
that have, they feel,
shirked a certain obligation,
a certain contract.
It may not feel
that way at Google--
and I don't really
want to speak,
since I don't work
here-- but in many places
you, just find
that-- and I think
this happened over
the '80s and '90s.
One of the things I don't talk
about in that little cubicle
section is that the sense of the
cubicle as being this bad place
really took off in '90s, when I
think layoffs were more common,
permanent employment
became much less common.
In the '50s, you got
a job and you kind of
thought you would stay there.
And then you didn't.
And so then the
cubicle became the sign
of this callous
workplace environment.
It's like, oh this
company doesn't care.
They just stuffed
me in a cubicle,
and they're probably
going to lay me off.
So, when you want to look at
the future of the workplace,
I think, if you
look at freelancing,
if you look at temping, if you
look at that sort of activity,
if you look at people even just
wanting to work from home more,
people seeking certain
kinds of flexibility
in their work lives.
I think you see a real
desire for autonomy
when it comes to determining--
it may even be little things,
like just how your work day
goes, how you do your work,
and where you do it.
Or it may even be just
controlling your work
entirely outside the confines
of a corporate environment.
And so that's where for me,
when it comes to the balance,
I tend to load
things on what's good
for the workers of the company,
rather than the office space
thing like, "Is this
good for the company?"
I think the workplaces
I visited that seemed
to exude more control by the
employees over what they do,
that tends to be the
most tangible thing.
And control can take
many different forms.
In workplaces like the
ones in Silicon Valley,
I think one of the
things that you
see is the reason a lot of these
places are so-- a lot of them
put a lot of care into--
which is an unusual.
And that also, in
a way, reflects
a certain kind of
mobility for the people
who work in these places,
that they can move,
you have to retain them.
There's a tighter labor market,
or a way in which workers
seem to feel that
they have a little bit
more control over
their own choice, yes.
You may not even be making
demands in a certain way,
but there's an
unspoken, latent idea
of how the workplace should be.
And that, I would hope, would
be the case in throughout.
That's a better situation
than a lot of people have.
so that's sort of a long answer,
because it's a big question,
but yeah.
AUDIENCE: You alluded to briefly
the open office, open floor
plan in your opening.
I was wondering if you have any
thoughts about how it relates
to what you're describing
in terms of answering
the last question or just
cubicle life in general
you were describing earlier.
NIKIL SAVAL: Absolutely.
Open office plans.
Do you people know-- I'm going
to steal a joke from something.
Do you people know
the blog or the book
"Stuff White People Like"?
if you don't know it, it's
just a list of things,
like-- I can't even come up
with a good example now--
but like cafe lattes.
White people like cafe lattes.
It's a way of classifying
a certain kind
of upper middle class
white taste, right?
And one of the things they list
in "Stuff White People Like"
is open office plans.
And the joke is that
you grow up in America
and you have this inexplicable
loathing for the cubicle.
You just hate it, even
before you've worked in one.
And so the first
thing you want is
to work in an open office plan.
And so there's things
like doing data entry
or pushing code in a cubicle
is somehow mindless drudgery,
but doing the same thing
in an open office space
with exposed brick walls is
somehow creative and explosive.
I mean, I'm paraphrasing.
But the thing about
the open office plan
is-- I understand the
rhetoric behind it,
that it's meant to
encourage collaboration,
it creates a certain kind of
symbolic notion of openness,
transparency.
If people are familiar with the
Bloomberg offices in New York
City, which is big.
Each desk is like five by five
answer and they[re slightly
partitioned and your
just crammed together.
It's open and there's this huge
floor plan you just see across.
It's noisy, it's buzzy.
These are often
very pretty spaces
that have little basis in
psychological research,
how people actually work,
what they should actually do.
I think the rush to do it
is a big mistake, frankly.
I just think there are ways
in which the offices that
include openness as part
of their work space--
the ones that are better, you
have to be able to retreat
to a private space,
to take a phone
call, just to get
away from noise.
The fact is, they're
very distracting.
They often repeat the mistakes
in cubicle environments,
because you can hear noise.
And added to that is
visual distraction.
You just are
constantly surrounded
by visual distractions.
And distraction has
always been a problem
in office environments.
There's just very rarely
room for private work
or concentrated work.
And that's most work.
I mean, it differs
by sector, et cetera,
but most work you
actually have to just
put your head down
and concentrate.
So, there's a way in which the
open office plan is repeating
a certain kind of
mistake that we
made with the office cubicle.
Also I should've mentioned
this just briefly.
The open office plan is not new.
The kind of rage
for it now is new,
but in the 1950s is when
the first open office
plan was invented.
And it was invented in Germany
by two designers working
for the publishing
company Bertelsmann,
and it was called an office
landscape, a Burolandschaft.
And it was exactly like
the open office plans
today-- swirling patterns
of desks, no hierarchies.
Everyone had the same
kind of location.
It was egalitarian
in terms of design.
It was really popular among
architects and designers,
but workers in Europe actually
rejected open office plans,
because they had councils,
union- like structures,
the traditions of
social democracy.
And they were like, no way.
We hate these places.
We can't do any work.
They're noisy.
Egalitarian or not, if you're
a CEO in an open office plan,
you're still a CEO.
That doesn't change
your understanding
or makes you more approachable.
So they moved radically
away from the way
the US was trending and
towards private offices.
Studies are equivocal, but they
show that they don't-- you can
still collaborate
in private spaces.
You can still do a lot of
things that you need to do.
And in some ways, it's
easier, because if everyone
has a private space,
that's egalitarian too.
So I guess I'm not hiding
the fact that I'm really
against open office plans.
I find that the claims
advanced on their behalf
are totally exaggerated.
And certainly, if you want to
include that kind of space,
you have to make huge
provisions for private space.
And, in a way, they're
imposed on people,
regardless of what they
actually have to do.
AUDIENCE: Your comment
at the beginning kind
of implied that you recognize
that this book and this topic
does suffer from a lack of
upfront sexiness, as it were,
which creates an interesting
marketing problem for the book.
I know for myself
that I was-- there's
a Hebrew saying, I was kind
of favorably disappointed,
or whatever.
But this was hugely enjoyable.
Very interesting, very
enlightening, in many ways,
but you can see that, I
mean, it's not exactly
people are hanging by the doors
because they can't get in.
NIKIL SAVAL: What are
you saying? [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: So, I'm
just kind of wondering
what your thoughts
are about this.
Or, just the way it is--
you wrote your book,
and whoever comes, comes?
NIKIL SAVAL: Oh.
Well, I have to say
I've been actually
pleasantly surprised
by the response.
I mean, even though people are
not hanging off the rafters
and throwing their bras at
me, it's been-- or underwear.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean
to make that gendered.
The point of this, I think, was
that office work is so common,
a part of so many people's
lives, especially in the West,
and increasingly in
other countries as well.
And I, as a worker, wanted
to make this meaningful
for myself.
In a way, I wrote this
book for people like me.
And in a sense, I know
offices are different,
industries are different,
workplaces are different,
but there's also a show
called "The Office," which
speaks to a certain kind
of collective experience
that, however varied,
is nonetheless common.
I think that was the sort
of person I was writing for.
And in a way, I feel
like in speaking
to people about the book when
I was writing and since, what
is always elicits
is someone trying
to tell me about their office.
They're like, Oh, let me
tell you about my office.
I think there has been-- I've
been surprised by the interest.
Some of the reviews
have been OK.
And some of them
even say, "I thought
this book would be boring
and it's not boring."
I leave that to you,
of course, to decide.
You may find it totally dreary.
AUDIENCE: Judging
by the talk-- and I
guess you do make a good point,
even if one in 1,000 office
workers, 100 office workers
thinks it is interesting,
wants to know more, that's
already a nice niche chunk,
there's some market there.
NIKIL SAVAL: Yeah.
I hope so.
But yeah, it's the
idea is that it's
an essential part of
my life, our lives.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So, I was
curious if the book treats
at all the topic of the
extension of the office
into the home, the home
office, and basically
the cubicle-ization of
the home environment.
You think of loft living
and live- work environments.
I don't know if they are
historical precedents for that,
that extend beyond into
the 19th, 18th centuries.
But it seems like
with virtualization,
with telecommuting, it's
more the case now than ever
that people are setting up
offices within their own homes.
And I'm wondering if they
are taking office metaphors
that you would find in a
more collective environment
and transposing
them to the home,
or whether they're coming up
with new ways of interacting
all together.
NIKIL SAVAL: Yeah,
it's a very good-- yes.
The short answer is yes,
that I did treat it.
It's a very difficult
topic to talk about,
in a way, because
it's so talked about.
And actually, when I
was finishing the book,
the kerfuffle over the Yahoo!
CEO's Marissa
Mayers, I'm sure this
was the topic of discussion,
eliminating telecommuting
came up.
There is this history of it.
People started
foreseeing telecommuting
as a real thing in the 1970s.
I think Business Week ran
a series about this in 1975
called "the office
of the future."
If you guys are familiar with
the futurologist Alvin Toffler,
he's this old famous dude that
had sold millions of his book,
"The Third Wave."
That might be wrong.
But it's from the early 1980s.
He foresaw that the increased
use of telecommuting
would depopulate downtowns,
that everyone would suddenly
be working in these networked
electronic "cottages,"
he called them, out
in the countryside.
And there would
be no more cities.
Why would you have them?
You wouldn't need
skyscrapers, you
would just have people
working at home.
The curious thing is-- and this
is sort of my interest in it
and the way I sort
of connect it--
is that this hasn't happened.
In a way, though, the
office has bled out
of the building envelope,
and being set up
in homes, and into
all areas of life.
It has somehow created a
need for more concentration.
What you see is
actually people working
in city- like environments
or really wanting density,
in a certain way.
And the city sort of
informally right now--
but I think in there
are planned efforts
at this, like Tony
Hsieh in Las Vegas--
to actually set up cities
that support work anywhere.
So the issue is not just
homes, although that's
interesting in terms of
the erosion between leisure
and work that is
already quite advanced.
But also obviously
cafes, the rise
of coworking facilities,
which is largely
to support freelancers but
it could support any of you.
And if you needed to
work at, whatever it is,
like NextSpace or something.
So, in a way, the real
context to consider
that, that kind of
expansion of work
is the urban environment,
that cities are in some ways
are turning into
large workspaces.
Universities are talking about
giving up more space to people
to work in them I think
that's where I see the trend.
And, in a way, it points
to a kind of new raison
d'etre for cities themselves,
is to function as these expanded
workplaces.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's funny
because, at the same time,
you've got say,
in San Francisco,
you've got a lot of class
and political conflict
at the moment right now about
San Francisco being a feeder
city into basically
corporate office parks,
the great corporate office
park of Silicon Valley overall.
And a lot of people
have answered, well,
one of the solutions to that is
greater telecommuting, right?
If you can densify
within a given city,
and the city is just going
to become a feeder city,
well, you could allow people
to work from their homes.
So, there's a tension between
I guess the terror of one's
home becoming the
office, and also
the Utopian aspect of
that at the same time.
It's hard to know exactly
where that will pan out.
NIKIL SAVAL: Yeah, I mean that's
a very complicated question.
Some of the people within that
particular situation, I think,
some the proposals involve
densifying the actual offices,
like the campus offices.
One of the critiques is that
they suck economic activity
out of the surrounding
environment.
Having a cafe in
Facebook or Google
means that you don't have
it-- or it's less likely--
that you would have it
for those workers outside
and then for anyone else.
And the other thing
that you said,
there are more people
moving to San Francisco
and commuting by
bus or what have you
to the offices down south.
It's a more complicated
issue than people
just simply moving
into that city.
The city actually
supports those activities
and doesn't support
public housing.
It doesn't support ways to
keep people in San Francisco.
There's a way in which
it doesn't provide
economic activity that
is varied or diverse.
And that's been true of San
Francisco for the last 30
years.
I'm not saying that
this class conflict
isn't real and important.
AUDIENCE: It has a long-standing
generational history, yeah.
NIKIL SAVAL: But yeah.
It's accelerated tremendously
in the last few years.
And the reasons for that are
not just people moving in.
[APPLAUSE]